listen man I'm a big fan of your work uh
it's always cool to talk to you
thank is that the DeLorean in the
background there it is I was just in a a
Make-A-Wish Foundation event in Orlando
Florida about a month ago and they had
uh well I'm sure there's a couple of
them sure but they had one there and the
guy was like it was like this is one of
the originals and uh it was pretty cool
I got a really cool photo sitting in it
so kind of a little little fan geek
moment for me I love the Back to the
Future movies and obviously you know
Back to the Future too with the you know
it's uh anyway
um uh I have a million questions for you
uh if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why oh wow
um
you know I don't know why well I you
know there's
oddly as soon as you said it three came
to mind
um uh right off the bat one is his film
that I made a few years ago called
Colebrook
um because I made that to do with uh my
best buddy and it's a film about
friendship and I don't know it just
probably speaks most to me and that's
why I co-wrote it and wanted to make
this film you know the other two that
popped up right away and and I don't get
that question often is
um both happen to be based on true
stories and one is Black Hawk Down and
the other is perfect storm
um and I think
you know oftentimes when they think
about those two films in particular uh
you know there was such a commitment
um about what the story that you were
telling uh because it did affect real
people uh and families that are still
alive and friends that are still alive
of the people that were in these films
and that always had a weight to me that
that meant something and it meant it
meant a lot to everybody I know uh the
guys when we worked on Black Hawk Down
over in Morocco we had some of the
people that were were in Somalia there
with us and uh talking to us and help
training us and and
they knew these people that didn't come
back home and and it was a big deal to
them that we got it right
uh and the same thing when we were
shooting uh Perfect Storm and we went to
Gloucester Mass and shot in the little
town and and the families of the members
that were on the injury gal when I had a
chance to meet some of them and the
family of the guy that I was playing and
that carries um an awful lot of
responsibility to to uh be honorable and
uh so
those are my three of the day sure uh
I'll be listen man as I said I could die
I could dig down in so many of your
roles in so many different movies but
jumping into why I get to talk to you
today one of the things that I really
enjoyed was uh Robert really cut this
thing so it is Breakneck especially like
that first hour is Non-Stop and it's
like it keeps it's always pulling the
rug out from under you what was it
actually like reading the script for the
first time uh because it's it's a cool
project fascinating reading the script
for the first time I was on a flight
from Sydney Australia to La uh just you
know right before I got on the plane I
got an email it was from my agent and
said hey here's this Robert Rodriguez
film if you like it like to have a zoom
with you so right away I'm like
Robert Rodriguez okay that's like in in
my bucket list of people I want to work
with uh read the film and you know some
some stories you know I you could be you
know 30 speakers into it and go oh okay
I know what's going on I I don't think I
thought that throughout the entire first
time that I read the film
um it was a Paige Turner kept kept you
going uh things started to reveal
themselves and just when you thought you
knew what was real all of a sudden it
might be real but it might not be and
that goes with the character that I play
as well so everything was pretty
fascinating just reading it talking to
Robert the next day when I got back to
LA it was a great conversation and then
uh three weeks later uh I'm hanging out
in Austin making this movie but I love
you know I totally agree with I love uh
what he's uh
you know the movie runs an hour and 33
minutes and it's it just moves and
obviously that's that was a choice you
know we shot a lot more than that but
the way Robert pared it down and it's
like the story has to fly and I I
thought it and you know until the
moments when when you really need
something else in a moment you know I
find that uh uh Alicia Braga who plays
Diana in the film and uh she is so
earthy and wonderful and grounded and
and she explains things that you might
think of as Exposition but it never
feels that way because she's so
brilliant when she's explaining the
world and trying to help Ben Affleck's
character understand where he is
um uh you know all of that's you know at
the end of the day it really reflects
back on on who Robert is and the kind of
filmmaker he is I agree with you I hate
watching a movie and I'm like oh here's
the exposition dump but I never felt
that in this no no and she's and she's
you know I had a chance to see the film
in South by Southwest Robert today work
in progress screening there and I flew
down to see it because I was so excited
I had such a great time working on it I
really wanted to see it put eyes on it
for the first time and and uh
I I literally sent her a message after
and I'm like darling you just boy did
you ground that you you are just so
Soulful and the depth you bring is that
character boy wow I was blown away I
could be wrong but I believe this is the
first time you've worked with Ben since
Armageddon
uh I I you know got to be honest with
you I
I think I've only ran into Ben once
um over those last like 25 years or
whatever it is I think Armageddon is 25
oldest this summer but um uh yeah but
you know such as such as life and you
know sometimes it swings around
sometimes you work with people you had a
great time with it and you never you
know work with him again and this was
this was a very interesting thing you
know obviously Ben is a very different
guy I'm a different guy and here we are
years later
um playing characters that's uh
uh are very intertwined yeah listen I
could spend eight minutes just talking
about Armageddon because I love that
movie I think it's one of Michael Bay's
best films uh but I I definitely want to
touch on working with Robert
specifically because he also shoots he
directs he writes he literally wears
every hat or his one of his kids is
wearing the other hat so what is it like
working with someone uh like that
because there's not many filmmakers that
do what Robert does the very first day I
love telling this story the very first
day that I went I I got to Austin they
had already been shooting for I think
about a week
they were doing a lot of things with
Alicia and and Ben and um got off the
plane dropped my bags and I went for a
wardrobe fitting so I went out to
Robert's studios in Austin and uh had a
chance to meet some of the folks and and
step down Set uh to say hello to Robert
in person I'd met Robert once before
like oh God I don't know 15 years ago
but only a couple of minutes so I went
to see him and Robert said here I'm
going to show you something literally
took me in another room which is you
know all the rooms in Robert's Studio
have
fascinating artifacts from all the films
that he's made
um whether it's Spy Kids or this that
and he's got all these cool things all
over the place and he takes out his
computer and he shows me uh a scene that
he shot yesterday
and so Robert goes home we sh listen we
shot things one day I'm set in the
morning and then after lunch Robert
showed me like a rough cut uh and he
showed me something that he shot the day
before and he goes like I just want to
give you an idea of like you know this
is we're working on this scene right now
and that was Robert every day so really
what that gave me not only is it
fascinating to see somebody who has that
sort of process
but
because Robert has such infinitive
thoughts and vision about things I don't
think I ever walked on a set and was
more interested right from the get-go of
course I'm always going to show up with
my own ideas and choices and thoughts
about who the character is but I would
show up and when Robert would start to
explain moments and details about things
I I was all focused all I wanted to do
is just find exactly what he was looking
for because I just so trusted his vision
about what hypnotic was going to be on
that note I need to wrap with you uh oh
they're going to throw me out I'm just
going to say man it's a pleasure to talk
with you and I wish you nothing but the
best thank you so much really appreciate
it